excellent as I mentioned this morning
the Victoria and Albert museum's it's in
London and the house South Kensington
between ourselves the Natural History
Museum and the science museum we attract
more visitors to London than visit
Venice each year we've about 2.9 million
objects about seven miles of museum
space and we're playing will becoming a
very international organization
currently building a museum in China
Dundee and two others one will be the
largest museum in the UK for over 100
years i'm here today to talk about the
cast courts at the Victoria and Albert
Museum take up a very small part of the
museum's a fairly small part of the
collection but it's a collection that
was built up by our founding director
henry cole built upon a convention
signed in 1867 their castes and copies
of european monuments and sculptures and
they were built up for the purpose of
education to give access to people who
didn't then have the money in funds to
be able to experience the great
monuments of the day they were not
actually put in place as a preservation
and protection method but they were
there to share the vision and to educate
and they conclude as well as a car see
also include electro types and other
forms of copies it's particularly
strange that i'm standing here talking
about the value of copies when I spent
ten years of my life arresting people
for fakes and forgeries for using copies
in a different way and now I'm
suggesting that they are the way forward
but I genuinely believe they are and of
course there's a big difference in
another lecture on the difference
between a copy and a fake and so on the
right you can see the cars courts as
they sit at the V&A at the moment
there's two courts the one on the right
here the italian court and then on the
left the is not the italic or even
though it's got Trajan's column in it is
the old picture from from when they were
originally formed so Martin wrote the
director will speak tomorrow at the
information and data workshop a little
bit more about this
we are entering into a collaboration
with the Venice architectural biennale
and we'll run the first partnered or
shared exhibition space that there the
event is held and it will be entitled
the world of fragile parts and it's
looking at copying as preservation and
it opens up a number of profound
critical questions concerning the
authenticity and value and how we choose
what to copy the quality of information
included in that copy and the purposes
to which we apply copies the exhibition
is running from like I say may to
November and it's designed to be a
little temporary laboratory for the
study of copying and preservation the
curator for this vni creator called
brendan kuya has developed to the
display and and will welcome feedback
during the course of that event he would
effectively be looking at the first part
the copying of the preservation the
reasons why and what should be done you
can say Martin will speak a lot more
about this tomorrow there in that
display at highlights there are four
main reasons why we should revisit the
prac the power and the value of copies
of course destruction from violence
destruction from natural disasters
destruction from tourism and
urbanization as well so this is the
original and I'm not going to read this
but this is the entire 1867 convention
it's a very simple word document it was
drawn up by henry cole started in 1861 i
believe with the assistance of the
Foreign and Commonwealth Office in the
United Kingdom and it was signed and
ratified over the course of seven years
by fifteen crown heads of state and it
basically says we've all got lovely
things and we should share them and we
should make them accessible to everybody
it doesn't say much more than that but
that's that's it it takes up on the
right hand slide there you can actually
see the original convention the first
page and a half of it is the is the
convention and the second page a half in
it is the signatures of the 15 crowned
heads of state
so when looking at the value of copy
I've put three slides up at three
pictures up here William Vaughn boat on
the left hand side the later director of
the Berlin museum's suggested that just
a small fragment of an original was a
far greater value than the cast of a
complete masterpiece and this attitude
throughout the 1920s definitely gained
pace with curators who believed that
casts and copies had no real value
within a museum however in the middle
picture there david was presented to the
Victoria and Albert Museum as a token of
diplomacy sort of diplomacy maybe by the
grand duke duke of tuscany to queen
victoria after he refused to lend an
object to the National Gallery in London
he unprompted sent their entire cast of
David over to London as a form of
compensation and of course I ask the
question here as well with Greek and
Roman copies why do we value Roman
copies of Greek sculpture any more than
maybe we caught value more modern copies
of other objects so looking at the value
of copy the victorian albert museum has
in the past shared space the
architectural courts were had both
copies and originals within them because
they were there for the same purpose to
train educate and inspire architects
designers and students of the day and on
the bottom left-hand side there you can
see the the screen there from that now
sits the Medieval Renaissance galleries
but at the time it was in with the
cast's in the architectural courts at
the V&A so then there's some reasons why
casts have become important to us the
second largest collection in the world I
believe of Cass was held at the Crystal
Palace display the Victoria and Albert
Museum a number of others including the
British Museum try for many years to get
the copies to form a national collection
of casts but were unable to do so and
unfortunately hundreds and hundreds of
these casts were destroyed during the
fire and those that remained started to
to join the Victorian habits collection
there are also items such as this Christ
washing the feet of his
disciples from lubick cathedral in
Germany which is the only surviving copy
the original that's been was bombarded
and destroyed during the war and so the
only record of that object exists in
cassville at the Victoria and Albert
Museum there's also the value of casting
something in eighteen sixty and and its
deterioration today this is an element
from Trajan's column in Rome of course
the right-hand side so in the damage now
from pollution and erosion and the left
hand side the copy the cast as it was in
1867 in a really far better condition
than it is today so the idea at the
moment is for the Victoria and Albert
Museum to enter into a first stage to
rewrite a convention to rewrite the 1860
kin 67 convention conveniently a hundred
and fifty years after the original he'll
be very much the first stage in a
three-stage operation but we want it to
be international we want it not just to
be a European exchange it needs to be an
international exchange taking advantage
of our position as an international
museum to encourage people from around
the world to share their objects and to
give access to those objects here as
well the idea is to open up the
collections to a wider audience preserve
objects for future in generations and to
record change as well we quite like the
idea of the the timeline that exists on
Google Earth where you can go back and
look at a different area in different
times throughout history and with 3d
scanning as we've just seen from sauk
the idea that you might be a one day to
walk into an exhibit and to see how a
building or a monument has changed
through our history we think would be a
fantastic experience so how would this
work well the first convention was the
first convention was very much about a
shop window just providing objects that
could then be seen by other people so
you would tell the world that you had
these objects and then involve
one-to-one negotiation to get a cast of
that copy and to send it to the museum
for display what we're hoping to do is
to create a virtual sharing where
by uploading the data that you have on
your objects by consent you also agree
at the same time to the use of those
objects by other partners for certain
things so removing all of those
obstacles that could be put in the way
and allowing objects to transfer and to
provide opportunities for people to see
them all over the world I'm last night
very bad form of me to be over time this
is how we may be the the car school
should be seen in the future not as a
space as he's depicted there on the
left-hand side within a museum but
actually just as an event something that
you could walk into and these gold boxes
of particularly struck me by mr Bakshi
there's one here at yard at the moment
where you walk in and meet someone from
a different part of the world it would
be wonderful maybe to be able to walk in
and experience objects from around the
world as a visitor to an area and it's
very final one is just there slightly
just the glimpse into the future we're
working with Essex University we've dr.
Tim chunky we're looking at touch
technology so not only will you see a 3d
scan but you'll actually be able to
touch it through gloves and he's
developing a technology which will
hopefully be refined enough to allow a
visitor or a student to fear leavin the
wood grain on an object within within
that piece let's move
you